yeah I have a decent rush hour for most
drivers but it has been a nightmare on
the Northbound I-15 because of a crash
that happened before two o'clock this
morning I don't know what the deal is
with this big slowdown on the eastbound
side of the northern 250 Beltway because
this crash was on the North 15 at the
speedway Bowl here's a live picture from
the Regional Transportation Commission
camera Nevada State Police Highway
Patrol telling us that a car that a
truck clipped the guard rail and Spilled
its entire load of diesel fuel the Tweet
saying no injuries here's a live picture
from our photographer on scene telling
us that the truck has been moved but
look at that crumpled up guardrail as
they continue to try to clean up the
mess from the diesel fuel so yeah
technically a little bit of progress but
for you it is still a major backup so
here's what we're talking about in terms
of the backup this the north 15 that
flyover ramp that we talked about being
open to get under the Western Northern
Tiffany Beltway some folks are trying to
get off a Tropical Parkway but wow huge
backups so while the diversion is
technically a closure the backups are
huge you might try getting over to Las
Vegas Boulevard but this turns into kind
of a toss-up like you're going to a race
at the speedway where you don't know if
the traffic's worse on the 15 or on Las
Vegas Boulevard but that is an option
for you we'll be watching the freeways
throughout CBS mornings and Good Day Las
Vegas will be